يشفع منص
يا الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام السلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا
اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
الوجيز في فقه السنه والكتاب العزيز
صيام التطوع
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول المؤلف
بعد ذكر 6ه من شوال
يقول الثاني والثالث يوم عرفه لغير الحاج
وعاشوراء
ويوم قبله
عرف
عاشو
عرفه عاشور
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول المؤلف عن ابي
قتاده
قال سئل رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم عن
صوم يوم عرفه سئل
عن صوم يوم عرفه يعني عن فضل صوم يوم عرفه
قال يكفر السنه الماضيه والباقيه
وسئل عن صوم يوم عاشوراء
يعني عن فضل يوم عاشوراء صوم يوم عاشوراء
فقال يكفر السنه الماضيه والحديث عند
الامام مسلم في صحيحه ابو قتاده
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عرفه
عرف
‏and come
was asked about
furراء
10 day of محرم which he
will act
for
‏year of sin and me here by sin are the
minor sin minor sin ma sin are
predicated
forivent
toى
‏and few
[Silence]
ما لكم
الشرك
الشرك شرك
ها
الزنا
كل ما ذكر في الكتاب من احكام
من عقوبه
نعم صحيح ذكرنا ان العلماء اختلفوا كثيرا
في هذا لكن افضل ما قيل في ذلك وهو
ما
اييه
يرجع فيه الى ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما
ان الكبيره
حد ان حد الكبيره
كل
ما ذكر له عقوبه خاصه
كل ما ذكر له من عقوبه خاصه في الدنيا او
في الاخره يعني مثلا
سباب المسلم فسوق
سماه النبي فسوقا
هذه عقوبه خاصه صح ولا لا او مثلا اي في
حد او في مثلا اسم معين لمن فعل ذلك من
فعل كذا وكذا ف انا بريء منه او الله بريء
منه او ثلاثه لا ينظر الله اليهم يوم
القيامه ولا يزكيهم
او مثلا اي له عقوبه كيت وكيت او في النار
دركه معينه او ما شابه ذلك كل هذه تعتبر
تعتبر من الكبائر ا ذي
‏The a a major sin is distinguished
in the sense that any sin any
disobedience
that has a particular
repercussion
mentioned for it or a particular
punishment mentioned for it whether that
be whoever does this is
صلى الله عليه وسلم
anyquishment
for anyone whoes this or for instance
this person is to be flogged or this
person is not to be spoken to or for
instance in the hereaf
‏any
mention for
out this is to be a ma sin and what is a
minor sin a minor sin is anything that
is not a maor sin
right very easy it's kind of saying
what
‏is whatever
on there below it is free of dots. So a
major sin is any sin that has been
specified to have a particular
punishment. What is a minor sin?
Anything that's not a major sin. ‏So
when we say
that this will act as an expiation for
minor sin
we now take that
يقول الفضل بنت الحارث ان ناسا تماروا
عندها
يوم عرفه تماروا يعني
تناقشوا
تناقشوا عندها يوم عندها يوم عرفه في صيام
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال بعضهم
وهذا كان في حجه الوداع فقال بعضهم هو
صائم وقال بعضهم ليس بصائم
فارسلت اليه يعني ام الفضل
رضي الله عنها ارسلت اليه بقدح لبن
وهو واقف على بعيره بعرفه فشربه
والحديث عند البخاري ومسلم في صحيحيهما
ام الفضل بنت الحارث
عرفه
يا اخوان
الحجه الحجه
day of 12 month of
year after
they were on the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
was
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الفضل
‏milk
and
could
لكنه كان لا يرد اللبن صلى الله عليه وسلم
وكان من دعائه
انه دائما اذا شرب او اكل يقول صلى الله
عليه وسلم يحمد الله ويقول وارزقنا خيرا
منه الا اللبن كان يقول وارزقنا
وارزقنا
او
وزدنا منه صلى الله عليه وسلم فاللبن نعمه
فكان لا يرد اللبن فهي ارسلت بذلك الى
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
قدح قدح
[Silence]
قدح
عرفه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
wasouring
a person
on the day
‏was
so how the two narrations
we harmon them as sch haron them that if
a person is in they are making it is the
sun not to fast the day of but if they
عرفه
بخاري مسلم
ان شاء الله تعالى نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يفقهنا في
ديننا وان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا
بما علمنا وان يزيدنا علما والله اعلم صلى
الله وسلم على نبينا